[Música]
[Aplausos]
los ojos por un momento
e imaginemos qué sucedería si durante 20
días nos sacamos los residuos de nuestra
casa
ya podemos abrirlos
como es posible que en pleno siglo 21
aún sigamos depositando en una sola
bolsa que casi siempre es de color negro
todos los materiales que producimos en
casa en esta bolsa estamos acostumbrados
a depositar
pero bolsas plásticas pañales
toallas higiénicas cartón
etcétera
pues bien en bogotá diariamente se
producen 6500 toneladas de residuos de
los cuales gracias a los recicladores se
recuperan 1.300 toneladas
estamos hablando de que 6500 toneladas
hace énfasis a un edificio de 17 pisos
el último censo de la entidad competente
distrital arrojó ok en bogotá existen 22
mil 500 recicladores de los cuales
13.000 son mujeres y son el motivo por
el cual me encuentro aquí en frente a
ustedes
estas mujeres me enseñaron un día al
salir de mi casa
cuando vi a una de ellas reciclar pero
no la vi
para editan y sentada ella estaba
reciclando metiendo la bolsa en una
pantalla gigante de excrementos de
materiales sucios pero lo más impactante
fue ver que esta mujer reciclaba con sus
dos hijos a quien nos encanta llevar los
niños al trabajo
fabuloso pero lo triste es será que es
agradable llevar a nuestros hijos a
reciclar
pues no al tener esta inspiración note
como esta mujer detalladamente
observando la se agachó levanto sus
niños y coloco
a estos seres en un zorrillo el zorrillo
es un vete h un vehículo de tracción
humana que ellos utilizan para llevar su
reciclaje por las calles ella se fue
desapareciendo en la cuadra y yo me que
observando la
y ahí nació esta grande porque a sentir
la necesidad y sentía el poder de hacer
algo por ellas
es por esto que como ingeniera
industrial me puse las botas y me fui a
campo que es lo que más me encanta
quería es descubrir conocer lo que había
más allá de una mujer reciclando
y es así como llegué a una bodega en una
localidad específica de fontibón de
bogotá y encontré a una cantidad de
mujeres trabajando como hormiguitas
ellas tenían la capacidad de hacer la
separación de estos materiales que
recuperaban en las calles de una manera
tan fuerte como decir organizar cartón
con cartón vidrio con vidrio pez con pet
y notaba la sensibilidad que le ponían a
esta actividad y el amor con que lo
hacía y descubrí que justamente de esa
manera como lo hacía a sí mismo deseaban
recibir el dinero que les llegaba para
que para vivir para pagar sus arriendos
para alimentar sus hijos para pagarles
sus estudios y les podría contar 13.000
historias más de cómo ellas hacen esta
actividad
en medio de esta bodega conociendo el
recorrido que me dio una señora fabulosa
baja estatura llamada luz mila pero con
el alma de guerrera me dijo
yamilé el reciclaje sin recicladores es
basura entendí perfectamente lo que ella
me quería decir aún más me podré decir
por dios santo necesitamos trabajar pero
yo sola no puedo vamos a ir de la mano
si son 13.000 mujeres vamos a llegar a
las 13.000
en medio de todo el proceso de
conocimiento porque me determinó un día
completo conocer la bodega que no era
tan grande conocía a patricia una mujer
que desde que me saludó sentía esa
energía poderosa que tenía en su mano y
sentía esa conexión con que ella me
quería hablar por eso y le era innato
que traía en sus venas me dijo yo quiero
hacer la voz de mi población pero
desafortunadamente la ciudadanía son
quienes siempre me han callado por el
hecho de ser recicladores
pues me puse la tarea porque si algo lo
que me encanta hacer es tener retos
hicimos patricia vámonos de una vez a
una comisión ambiental local o sorpresa
cuando desafortunadamente un señor en
medio de una conversación le dijo le
dijo siéntate que tú eres recicladora
ahí fue la primera partida para decir
adelante patricia no te sientes
y se levantó de esa mujer y expuso lo
que quería hablar
esa fue la primera vez que patricia
hablaba frente a un escenario
hoy en día patricia no tiene agenda
cuando la llamó muchas veces no me puede
atender porque está ocupada dictando
capacitaciones conferencias en empresas
públicas privadas en colegios
universidades gracias al liderazgo que
logró empoderar desde este proyecto
poco a poco descubrí que en medio de eso
era que era una sola bodega de las más
de 1500 que hay en bogotá de reciclaje
estaban estas mujeres que tenían no
solamente las manos cansadas sino el
alma arrugada
porque muchas mujeres de que están ahí
nunca han podido expresar ni sentir el
valor que les da reciclar porque porque
están acostumbradas a recibir malos
tratos a recibir insultos por la
sociedad porque no nos hemos hecho cargo
de alzar la voz y decir vamos a trabajar
por ellas vamos a sacar adelante a estas
mujeres y como lo podemos hacer con un
gracias con una sonrisa con un vaso de
agua
si podemos era sorprendente conocer como
en este proyecto me fui dando cuenta que
ellas no sólo reciclan
sino que hay un grupo de mujeres que se
dedican a hacer manualidades como estas
bolsos billeteras ositos de bolsa
plástica una cantidad de elementos que
son hechos con sus uñas con sus manos
tienen una creatividad impresionante de
cada parte que hila se encuentra una
emoción en sus vidas
esta bolso contiene un valor muy grande
que no se paga con dinero por eso lo
guardo como un tesoro
allí entendí que ellas no están ahí
porque quisieron ser la mejor
recicladora del mundo sino porque la
vida las ha llevado por diferentes
situaciones a estar donde están
tienen sueños más grandes que este
escenario cada una de ellas mil cosas
que contar y por eso la tarea fue
sentarme a escucharlas a conocer sus
emociones
es por esto que necesitamos empezar a
trabajar necesitamos crear un puente
necesitamos ayudar a estas mujeres a
amar lo que hacen
porque así no vamos a terminar
impartiendo incapacidades en su trabajo
aquí estamos como siempre desde el
principio de pie con ellas en campo en
sus fuentes fijas en sus rutas
selectivas acompañando las defendiendo
las de quien las quiere maltratar porque
desafortunadamente somos nosotros mismos
quienes no entendemos que es un trabajo
dignificado el reciclaje y que ellas
necesitan de nuestra mano para sacar esa
luz
que las acompaña que de aquí en adelante
hagamos el propósito de descubrir esa
luz que ellas tienen en sus manos
porque hace esa luz que a mí me motivó a
estar aquí frente a ustedes y que es muy
importante que todos la conozcamos esa
luz que ellas necesitan expandir pero
que no lo pueden hacer solas no le
tengamos miedo cuando veamos una mujer
recicladora no luchamos no la
maltratamos no la justificamos por el
hecho de que no me acerco porque es
recicladora al contrario no se imaginan
el tesoro que vamos a recibir de ellos
si le brindamos una sonrisa y saben cuál
es ese tesoro
gracias porque para ella es decir
gracias es de muy pocas veces justamente
porque nadie lo hace con amor al momento
de entregar y reciclar saben ustedes
cuál es la pauta más importante que
necesitan estas mujeres de parte nuestra
separan los residuos si nos ocupamos de
hacer la separación de estos residuos en
casa estamos ayudando a que ellas no
tengan que meter la mano a la bolsa no
se tengan que hurgar no se tengan que
cortar sus manos
estamos ayudando a que cuando tengan que
llevar sus hijos a reciclar no tengan
que verlas así como desechables no
tengan que sentir que su mamita está
oliendo mal sino al contrario que se
inspiren en que su mamá es una guerrera
que es una valiente y que está ahí
sacando adelante su familia
es por esto que es de mi acompañamiento
he podido impactar a más de 400 mujeres
y lo seguiré haciendo cada día con más
de ellas porque la meta son más de 13
mil ojalá sean infinito a nivel mundial
donde reconozcamos su labor su gestión
pero sobre todo el compromiso de
nosotros mismos al momento de separar
los residuos en casa
de una u otra manera quiero invitarlos a
que miremos al siguiente vídeo
lo más duro es de este trabajo es la
falta de conciencia de la gente así que
no se concientice que el reciclador es
un trabajador más
que el reciclador merece respeto que el
reciclador merece honra si ve no
solamente el que trabaja en la oficina
necesita de un buenos días de un buenas
tardes sí sino que también el reciclador
que está ahí separando esa basura
necesita de buenos buenas noches buenos
días cómo está un hasta luego si eso es
lo más duro que lo logres estigmaticen a
uno porque uno es reciclado
ahí está nuestro deber
y nuestro deber es brindarles respeto
brindarles cariño no necesitamos abrazar
las porque muchas de ellas son esquivas
nos tienen miedo a la sociedad
nuestra tarea está básicamente en
entregarles el material separado y
porque no en fin de año que ella les
fascina recibir casi siempre nosotros
cambiamos de closet cada año porque no
la ropa lavada planchada y entregada
para ellos es un valor muy grande con el
amor que reciben estos objetos estos
temas a veces cambiamos solo en nuestra
casa ellos lo necesitan no se lo demos a
alguien que lo arroje a un punto crítico
porque de nada sirve si no pensemos en
ellos al momento de implementar todos
nuestros utensilios orgánicos en casa
pensemos en cómo debemos darles la
posibilidad de que ellos se reutilicen
porque miren la cantidad de elementos
con los que transforman el reciclaje y
esto es poco para lo que yo les pudiera
contar me encantaría poderlos llevar
trasladar al mundo desconocido que todos
tenemos de estas mujeres pero que he
logrado adentrarme en sus hogares en sus
familias algunas de ellas en su dolor
porque necesitan de nuestro apoyo de
nuestra luz están solas
pocas estamos alzando la voz los brazos
las manos en decirle ven aquí están
están acompañadas nuestras mujeres nos
necesitan la mayoría de ellas son madres
cabezas de hogar muchas son solteras
otras casadas pero no tienen un nombre
que las ampare que las proteja tienen
que atravesar la ciudad ocho o diez
horas caminando en el día en la noche
hospedarse debajo de un puente para
poder descansar y su única defensa su
única defensa son sus manos porque el
sitio donde mayor equidad de género
existe es en el reciclaje porque está
allí donde están de tú a tú con el mundo
allí por el hecho de hacer mujer no
quiere decir que no levante un bulto más
pesado que el hombre o menos pesado allí
el tema es igual para todos
y allí he podido aprender que la fuerza
está en la pasión y cuando nos
apasionamos por algo lo logramos así
cada una de ellas ha logrado salir
adelante ha logrado crecer y ha logrado
decir hoy
todo es posible muchas gracias
[Aplausos]